الان محمد فرحات
الى خرسون اهلا بك محمد
نتوقف معك عند مستجدات وتطورات الوضع
الميداني خصوصا في الجبهه الشرقيه
الاوكرانيه
مرحبا وداد بالفعل مدينه خرسونيه الجبهه
الجنوبيه في هذه الحرب الاوكرانيه وهنا
اكثر من خمسه
من سكان هذه المدينه غادروها بشكل يومي
هناك المئات ايضا يتجهون نحو محطه
القطارات وايضا الحافلات التي تقلهم على
الاقل نحو مدينه ميكولايف القريبه والتي
تعتبر امنه نسبيا كما تشاهدين خلفي هذه
المدينه تحولت الى مدينه اشباح هذه الساحه
التي كانت في شهر نوفمبر مركز للاحتفالات
احتفال استعاده هذه المدينه الاستراتيجيه
هذه المدينه التي تعتبر القلب النابض لالا
جنوب الاوكراني الان هي شبه خاليه ومركز
المحافظه هذا المقر الذي تم ايضا قصفه وهو
مدمر
بالكامل في الجهه الاخرى
يعني هناك صعوبه للذهاب نجحنا مع الزميله
كاترين وايضا الزميل كريم اليحياوي في
الذهاب الى الجهه المقابله من النهر
هذه المنطقه الخطيره والتي فيها اشتباكات
بين القوات الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه
منذ قليل فقط تعالت يعني الله تعالى
الدخان هناك قصف الشبه عشوائي كل هذا
الوقت وهناك القليل من السكان الذين
حدثونا عن صعوبه هذه الحياه في ظل انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي وكل يعني مستلزمات
الحياه ودمار البنيه التحتيه بالك